[Musique]
revue de presse signée bill al arab et
bonjour by la largeur philo mais un
sujet pour commencer dont on parle très
peu ce matin à la une du washington post
la chasse aux collaborateurs présumés 1
et prennent vous c'est une plongée dans
une haie craie dans une ukraine libéré
et traumatisé selon les journalistes qui
prend la forme d'un carnet de voyage
assez pesant il faut le dire titré dans
les villages ukrainien les murmures de
la collaboration avec les russes le
washington post nous propose une plongée
dans ces localités qui ont été libérés
des russes ou bien dans les rues sont
partis et voici comment les deux
reporters du journal décrivent
l'atmosphère là bas je cite le
brouillard de la guerre a été remplacé
par la brume des soupçons et des
conspirations dans ce village par
exemple une femme raconte qu'elle a
surpris une nuit un voisin en train de
tirer des fusées éclairantes au bord
d'une route le lendemain une colonne de
chars russes est entré dans ce village
exactement par l'endroit où se tenait
cet homme qui a disparu d'ailleurs
depuis le départ des russes et elle
s'interroge cette femme peut être l'at
il fait pour l'argent je ne sais pas ap
six qui c'est un autre village qui a été
libéré les reporters du poste sont
accueillis par cet avertissement un
habitant leurs cris fait attention ici
c'est plein de ruciste entre guillemets
ce qui est un jargon local pour désigner
un mélange de russes et de fascistes
alors c'est un village d'à peine 800
habitants c'est tout petit tout le monde
se connaît et la directrice de l'école
du village lorsqu'elle a vu arriver les
russes se serait exclamé cela fait huit
ans qu'on vous attendait pour ramener
l'ordre avant de mettre son école à
disposition des russes pour qu'ils s'en
servent de base alors dans cette école
il y avait au mur des photos des jeunes
du village qui avait servi dans l'armée
ukrainienne dans le donbass depuis 2014
l'un d'eux a été emmenée par les russes
dans les bois où il a été abattu mais il
a survécu parce que la balle finalement
s'est logée dans son épaule il a déclaré
aux journalistes du post je suis allé
voir cette directrice et je lui ai dit
que sa vie était terminée parce que je
compte l'étranglait de mes propres mains
c'est que la lire dans le washington
post l'ukraine encore bilal où plane la
menace nucléaire toujours tout à fait au
delà des inquiétudes provoquées par la
simulation de tir à capacité nucléaire
on en a parlé par les russes cette
semaine à kaliningrad le correspondant
du monde à moscou nous décrit comment le
scénario d'une attaque nucléaire est
évoqué tous les jours quasi en russie
comme si c'était un débat de sujets
parmi d'autres un alors par exemple sur
la première chaîne de télévision un
présentateur montre une animation un
petit peu comme ce qu'on fait ici avec
les écrans qui décrit comment le royaume
uni seraient pulvérisées par le missile
sous marin de dernière génération
poséidon sur une autre chaîne il y ait
un débat et ce débat concerne un
comparatif du temps que mettrait une
tête nucléaire russe pour atteindre une
capitale occidentale par exemple 106
secondes pour atteindre berlin 200
secondes pour paris ou 202 pour londres
et il est à ce commentaire d'un des
experts en plateau ils sont impossibles
intercepté ils n'auront même pas le
temps de se retourner scénario très
effrayant bilal tarab et ce n'est pas la
première fois que le monde fait face à
une menace de guerre nucléaire non et
c'est pourquoi le figaro nous propose
cet article titré de façon d'ailleurs
extrêmement réjouissante c'est troisième
guerre mondiale auquel le monde a
échappé de peu voilà alors figurez-vous
j'ai compté le monde aurait échappé pas
moins de sept fois à une troisième
guerre mondiale on connaît bien sûr la
crise des missiles de cuba en 1962 mais
il ya aussi dix ans plus tôt pendant la
guerre de corée la fois où un aviateur
américain s'est approché un peu trop
près du port russe de vladivostok
il y as en 1956 quand des avions
soviétiques ont survolé la syrie pendant
la crise du canal de suez ou encore
accrochez-vous en 1969 quand un richard
nixon vraisemblablement ivre a ordonné
une frappe nucléaire sur la corée du
nord avant que
le conseiller à la sécurité de l'époque
henry kissinger n'appelle l'état major
en leur disant attendait peut-être
qu'ils se réveillent et qu'il est
dégrisé cette attaque n'a jamais eu lieu
en philo mais c'est troisième guerre
mondiale lequel le monde a échappé de
peu c'est dans le figaro autre chose
bilal après la menace du coc u19 la
menace du nucléaire toujours oui bah en
tout cas c'est le sens de ce cartoon du
dessinateur français pieds 1 donc on
voit que va-t-il nous arriver de nouveau
ce virus qui ressemble qu'ovide 19
essais têtes nucléaires qui si je
traduis lui dit oft est démodé
mieux vaut en rire qu'en pleurer
effectivement ça l'actualité politique
en france la nouvelle est tombée au
milieu de la nuit l'union de la gauche
en vue des législatives semblent eux
scellé avec le ralliement du parti
socialiste finalement à l'alliance avec
la france insoumise de jean luc
mélenchon tout à fait vous les vieux
vous l'évoquiez dans vos titres il y à
il ya quelques minutes alors c'est trop
tard pour libération qui a dû imprimer
son journal avant la décision mais
évidemment la nouvelle est en une du
site internet du principal quotidien de
gauche français alors ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que cette fois ci le
conseil national du parti socialiste a
été ouvert aux journalistes et donc au
delà du vote pour le oui qui a été plus
haut que ce que prévoyaient les
pronostics c'est à dire 62 % on a un
petit compte rendu des échanges verbaux
qui a eu lieu pendant ce conseil alors
notamment
cette phrase tu m'insultes a crié une
socialiste pendant qu'olivier fort le
premier secrétaire demandez à son camp
une clarification à savoir de choisir
entre sa ligne avec mélenchon ou
s'aligner avec macron et olivier faure a
conclut par cette phrase il y avait un
doute dans l'opinion qui s'exprimait
depuis cinq ans mais que nous n'avons
pas voulu entendre et sur un ton
beaucoup plus léger bilal vous avez
rappelé qu'en cette période d'élections
les correspondants étrangers en france
notamment les anglo saxons en profite
pour pointer les quelques petits travers
de la société française oui les travers
les spécificités alors on a souvent eu
les 2300 80 variétés de fromages qui
existent en france mais alors là il
s'agit de pas de ça il s'agit plutôt de
l'auto dénigrement du blues de la
sinistrose bref d'une déprime collective
typiquement française et qui laisse
perplexe les anglo saxons au point d'en
faire des slogans on a le blick chic qui
pourrait se traduire par triste c'est
chic ou bien encore heureux d'être
malheureux alors le monde nous explique
en fait comment les anglo saxons
tendance à juger la france beaucoup plus
de manière beaucoup plus positive que
les français eux mêmes et à leurs
chiffres à l'appui un emploi inflation
lutte contre le coc vie de 19 il montre
que finalement la france ne se classe
pas si mal voir plutôt bien si on la
compare à ses voisins européens
alors le l'article poursuit avec des
interviews de chercheurs en histoire ou
en sociologie qui disent que finalement
c'est une explication historique
la france n'a n'aurait pas digéré sa
grandeur passée merci beaucoup bilal
tarabet